i was curious about you because you said
at the beginning that even though your
mother had taught you in some sense
these woke precepts there was something
in you that rebelled against it yeah
it's what was that yeah it's not um
i don't rebel against the idea that for
example there is institutional racism i
don't think it should be called that but
there are inequities in society between
say black and white that are due to
racist attitudes usually in the past and
racist biases and racist lookings past
all those things are definitely true
there are all sorts of things in black
history that have helped to set us back
that one should certainly know about one
should know about the redlining of
neighborhoods where in many cities most
black people lived in neighborhoods
where banks would not give you a loan
all of these things are very real i
never felt like i rebelled against that
what i rebelled against was the idea
that you base your whole sense of
identity upon those things such that you
live a life that's abbreviated because
you're exaggerating how bad it still is
and you're distorting what's necessary
to create dignified lives for black
people and my feelings always been you
probably have about 80 years you know
you're lucky if you've got 80 years and
if you spend your whole life
maintaining in my time period the same
battle poses in the 80s and 90s that
people needed in the 50s and 60s after a
while you've spent your life play acting
and then you die and the world goes on
what i rejected was the exaggeration so
for example i remember what really if
there was one moment where i realized
there was something wrong with me it was
the in the wake of the rodney king trial
in 1991 and a lot of a lot of black
people i liked very much were united in
saying what happened to rodney king
shows that a black man can't get justice
in this country and i remember thinking
no
no that that statement would have made
sense in about 1965 and in many american
cities 1975 and there were islands of it
even in 1991 but the idea that as a
20-something black person you were
living in a country where you just
couldn't get justice it struck me as
beyond rhetoric especially given the
general attitude they had towards what
being black meant then as we were
standing around at stanford university a
campus where all of us had been
evaluated according to adjusted
standards out of the idea that we were
really wanted on that campus etc that we
were supposed to still be speaking that
language that the black panthers had
spoken it struck me as a pose and there
was a part of me that was deeply
disturbed by the artificiality of it and
that you were actually expected to live
it why why are the artifacts okay so you
again you use very specific words
artificial as opposed to what like what
on what page like you're comparing it to
something and it it sounds it sounds
like you're comparing it and and you
don't just regard it as an exaggeration
your criticism has gone farther than
that in the past i mean you you've also
uh
directly stated that
conceptualization of the problem in this
form is actually interfering with the
solutions that we still need to generate
so it's not just it it's not just an
exaggeration it's a problem in and of
itself and that's a deeper criticism so
so
so what's the artificiality as far as
you're concerned and yeah compared to
what
yeah what you're trying to live
apparently but what do you what is that
exactly
the question is how much of an obstacle
is racism after
formal segregation has been battled
after racial attitudes change profoundly
in the 1970s and i'm just old enough to
have watched that happen just it gets to
the point where okay racism does exist
both social and institutional but how
much of an obstacle is it to doing
pragmatic things that will make poor
black people less poor and all black
people happier so quick example would be
that these days you can look at the fact
that black kids tend not to do as well
on standardized tests yes
it's there now you can look at that and
you can say well if black kids don't do
as well on the test that's because of
racism and so we need to eliminate the
test because the test
is racist now in what way is the test
racist 40 years ago maybe those tests
asked you what wine goes with chicken
that hasn't been true for generations
now so it's not about asking people
things that they have no reason to know
how is it how is it racist and there are
people today who even will imply that
black thought is somehow incompatible
with tests like that which is very close
to saying that black people are
incapable of disembodied abstract
thought and many whites
identical without claiming yeah it's
it's very unfortunate especially given
that the people who are saying it know
very well the history of that being said
about black people and so you look at
the tests and you say that because black
kids don't do well on them they are
examples of systemic racism well you
have to get rid of racism so you have to
get rid of the tests which means that
you tell america that black kids can't
have their abstract reasoning measured
without it being racist and then when
you get somebody saying well then black
kids just must not be as quick on the
uptake you call them a racist and in the
meantime it's ignored that you consider
helping black kids get better at the
tests helping black kids parents realize
what free test prep programs there are
in those neighborhoods the tests just
take a little bit of practice but you're
not supposed to talk about it because
the tests quote unquote are racist
that's a it's an abuse of language and
it's abuse of the very conception of
what racism is that's not what my mother
raised me in that's not your
grandmother's racism that's something
that comes from a way of thinking that
was
marginal in 1955 became sexy in about
1966 and here in 2021 is being treated
as impregnable wisdom someone black has
to speak out against that so that's what
i mean by the exaggeration and the
artificiality and the outright harm that
comes from these sorts of things
well and it and with regard to it being
opposed
so is it is it is it a pose of
so i could say well is it a pose of
unearned virtue i mean virtue is not
easy to earn true virtue you have to
establish let's say we'll see we see we
would go with this maybe you have to
establish a relationship with beauty and
beauty is real you have to establish a
relationship with truth
and truth is real and so to earn virtue
is difficult because beauty and truth
are imposing and and and formidable
if you have any sense at all you see
that and so that's a daunting task to
establish genuine virtue and a
terrifying task and is the pose the
the the willingness to adopt see because
when i talk to the ideologue types and
maybe that happened most famously with
an interview i had with i think i was
just thinking about it
you mean michael eric dyson right yeah
oh i was no i wasn't thinking about
dyson i was thinking about uh gq
interviewer and that interview has been
watched like 40 million times now it's
this ideological pose is
it is the
aping of virtue as far as i can tell and
i i mean that and it's it's sort of a
technical sense is that you master this
language and it contains the expressions
of true virtue but you know the kind of
problems that you were talking about and
i see this on the environmentalist side
of things too uh well how do you get
black kids to do better in elementary
school let's say well that's a more
manageable problem it's a problem that
would take a little bit more more
humility to conceptualize and it's also
a really really hard problem
and so to be virtuous
in your attempts to solve that would
require it probably require the
dedication of your entire life really to
to take a good crack at that problem
right because
that's a tough problem man
and so maybe you don't want to do that
because it's
and then you're enticed and you're
enticed by your educators
into this
alternative
possibility where all you really have to
do is master a set of propositions and
you're on the winning side and that also
gives you some convenient enemies and
maybe it fulfills to some degree the
religious instinct and and it depauls me
to see the universities complicit in
this
and that they've come to see that
and i think part of that falseness and
artificiality that you
described i think the fact that that
exists is part of the
like overbearing insistence
that the veil not be lifted and that no
one questioned this because what is
underneath it is so damn ugly
yeah yeah yeah jordan you actually
you are um you have nailed something
i would be loath to go so near that word
virtue because the last thing i want to
do is imply that somebody isn't virtuous
nevertheless
you're getting it in that
it's an unearned virtue which people are
settling for not because they're so
callow as to which to be virtuous
without earning their stripes but
because religion is attractive and so if
you are surrounded by people who are
brandishing this message that everything
that you don't like is racist and you
can get beyond it that way it's not that
you're lazy it's not that you're trying
to get stripes that you didn't earn but
it's comfortable because part of being
in that religion is that there's an us
versus them conception which is very
comforting you're part of a mission of
uplift which is very comforting and in a
university that religion is there it's
as if they're you know people from a
church who are behind tables out in the
plaza who are waiting to recruit people
that's there as soon as you hit campus
and so
that's why so many people and now it's
not just black kids it's also white kids
fall for this way of looking at things
where what it is is
you become virtuous without having done
the sorts of things that ideally one
might have you can your virtue signaling
and it is unearned virtue but it's
because you wish to have a cloak you're
seeking a comfort zone i can't hate
anybody for that but it does mean an
awful lot of mendacity that's the
problem